今日はこのターナというところをでしょうか
ターナという言葉の意味は
まあまあ 一応場所という place という意味なんですけど
アビダンマではこの時空両方一緒に考えてるんですね
ターナっていると ただ
空間的な場所だけではなくて
時間的な位置もまとめてそこにターナというんです
ですから 例えばこれ ターナは場所として place として訳したら
空間の安定だけになっちゃうんです
で そういうふうに訳できないんですね
時間の関係も考えちゃうんです
ここではそちらの説明はないんですけど
ただその言葉の意味だけを覚えておけばいいし
で ここで問題にするのは
心はどこに生まれるかっていうことなんですね
で 今 心の働きから考えて
心はいろんな働きをする
この働きをすると どこにその働きをするかと
ですから 心っていうのは時間の流れだけで考えているんだから
心には空間がないんだから
働きだけですから でも働きになったらそこで空間というものも出てくるし
物質にしがみついて心は働いているんだから
物質は空間をとってますから
そういうことで 心が働くと
どこに働くか いつ働くか
どんな時に働くかということで
時空関係まとめてターナ
場所ということにしているんです
一番目のこのパティサンディというのは
結晶する心 五分 因典 五識
で  10種類が出てくるんだと
パティサンディっていうのは我々知っているこの生まれる心ですね
生命が初めてどこかに生まれが作っちゃうと
その最初の心にパティサンディっていう心と呼んでいます
で 輪廻として考えてるんだから
心は一つの流れとしてずっと流れてるんですね
電気の流れのように流れているものは心である
その瞬間 その瞬間心は変わるんだけど
一つの流れとしては同じもの
ですから 川とかね そういうものと例えてみるとわかりやすいし
川といってもそこでいつでも違う水が流れてるんですね
水一滴一滴見ると全部違うし
二度と同じ水がそこに流れることもないし
でも我々にとっては 現象的にはなんとか荒川があります
隅田川ありますというふうには言えるし
それは世間的な立場ではそれは正しいんだけど
心理の立場から見れば
隅田川といっても 瞬間瞬間水が流れていることだけがあって
そこに同じ水の一滴が二度と同じ場所を流れるということはありえない
ないんです で ただ簡単に言葉では隅田川とか荒川とかなんとかとか言うんです
心も同じなんです 心と言えば隅田川と言ったことと同じなんです
でも 心という実質的なものを考えちゃうと
いつでも川の水のように流れているもので
同じ心が二度と生まれてこないんです
ですから そこら辺で考えてみてほしい
我々の心もずっと川と同じように流れていくもので
同じことを繰り返して生まれるということはないんです
それに新しい心が生まれる
それ消えて次の心が生まれる
で 私たちは同じ心があるんだということは
それは人間の誤解であって
で その誤解をアビダンマを勉強するとどんどん消えていくんですね
なぜならば 我々にはやっぱり同じ気持ちですよという体験があるんですからね
で いつでも起こりますよと言ったら
自分がいつでも同じ怒りの心を作っているんではないかという体験があるし
で そういう同じ心が生まれたんだという体験
実験 実感がありますから
そこら辺はこのアビダンマの心の種類として
カテゴリーにして  89種類の心を挙げて説明しているんだから
そこら辺はそれは解決はできると思います
で 例えば怒りの心といえば
一応怒りの心 怒りの心ですけど
まるっきり同じ怒りの心が生まれるわけじゃないんです
その時その時生まれる心は違うんです
怒りの心だから我々は同じ心だとただ思う
そこで心が全く川のようなものであると理解すると
この水のこと 喋る場合はどういう風に喋ればいいんですか？その時はやっぱり時空両方まとめて喋らなくちゃいけない
この場所でこの時間でこの水の一滴がいましたと
で 例えば三丁目のところの水と言ったっても
それは違うんです 三丁目だけ言ったら
ずっとそちらの水が流れていっちゃうんですね
三丁目のところのもう三時三十三分三秒のところの時の水といったら
すぐそこにある水をちゃんと
確定しているんですね
そういうわけで 場所と言っても
ターナというパーリ語では場所という言葉を使ってますけど
時空関係両方まとめて場所を考えているんです
それは仏教の無常論に基づいている考え方なんです
ものは流れているんだから
そこで一番目はパティサンディという働きなんですけど
それはまああの心っていうのはずっと流れていると思っても
例えば私たちは人間として形ができたところで
体も流れていきますけど
変化していくんだけど
その中に心もずっと流れていくんですね
そこで人間という形が消えたところで違う形になってしまうんです
心はそれでも流れているんだそうです
だからといって 一つの確実に流れてくれる一定変化している心があるかというと
そうはないんです だから隅田川には隅田川たる水一部がないんです
どんな水でもいいんです
同じく私たる心というものはないんです
ですから 私がいて あるいは私の霊魂魂がいて
それは輪廻転生しているんだということを
仏教ではまるっきり考えていない
そんなことはないんだと
無我なんですが 実体はないんだけど
今も心が流れていくんだから
いろいろ訳があって流れているんでしょうね
それで急に止まったということはありえないんですね
我々も例えば心止まってみようと思ったらできますか？それは決してできないです
どう考えても どれほど瞑想したって心は流れていくんです
いろいろ集中することやら
心のレベルがそういうものを強くすることやら
そういうのはできますけど
心のレベルを超意識したレベルに持っていくとかできるんだけど
では心をストップしてみてくださいと言えば
それはできないんです
それできるのはこのこのヴィパッサナー瞑想の悟りの瞬間だけなんです
[咳]その瞬間では心が止まるんだけど
それは大変な仕事なんです
すべての生命の法則 宇宙の法則をもう全部もうやめて
もうところで生まれるんだから
これは出色現心と言うんです
で 他の瞑想ではどれほど高い境地の禅定を得ても
それでもその状態で心が流れているんです
ですから 流れるということは
何か原因があって流れるんです
その原因は後で別な項目で説明しますからね
なぜ心が流れるかということ
で ですから水と似ていて
水が流れると確実にそこに次の水が入っちゃうんです
それでないと その現象が存在しないんですね
例えば噴水があるんだよと言ったところで
水がずっと流れていくことはあって
噴水なんです 水が流れなければ
そこに噴水があるわけじゃないんです
ですから どうしようもないんです
噴水があるというならば
1つの水が出ていったら
次の水の 1点がそこにその場所に行くんです
そういうことで 人間でいて
我々の心はずっと流れている
そこで何か訳があって
この機械ですか 物体がもう壊れたり
その物体 その物体に心が流れることは不可能になるんですね
例えば目が見えなくなっちゃったら
そこで認識が生まれなくなっちゃうし
耳が聞こえなくなっちゃう
そこで認識が生まれたいんだけど
生まれなくなっちゃうし
そういうふうに体の機能は全部壊れていくことで
我々死と呼んだからね
どんどん老化して 機能できなくなっちゃって
脳細胞も壊れてしまっちゃって
で もう機能できなくなって
でも水は流れたい 心が流れたいんですよ
この場所で流れないんです
そこで自分がそれでも流れちゃう
ここで死んだ瞬間でも心が流れたら
その流れる瞬 次の瞬間に結晶心というんです
いわゆるこの体で心が止まる瞬間は死瞬間ですね
死の瞬間 で 次の瞬間で
の心に結晶心というんです
死んで それから次の人
次の瞬間 それのほとんど時間の我々感じる時間の距離
感覚がないんですね 今も私たちには心はもう流れているということは感じないんです
一つ一本で見えちゃうんですね
例えば阿弥陀様から来ると
何か目で見る 目でみると耳で聞こえないんですよ
耳で音を聞く瞬間で 目で物は見えないんです
でも我々は一度もそれを体験したことがないんですね
私たちにとっては同時にやってるんだと
見て聞いてるんだと 一緒にやってるんだと思うんですね
で それはもう速さなんですね
我々は物質に基づいて考えちゃいますから
物質より 17倍心が早く動いているんだから
そのわからないんですね
物質通って見ているし
耳という物質として聞いているし
ですから そこら辺で心には随分時間があるんです
で それはまあ分かりやすくするために
例えば 1本の針で 1箇所に穴を押すと
そこでゆっくりやっちゃうと
こちら穴を押して次の場所に穴を押す
それで我々はそれをどんどんスピードアップする
そうすると 左と右とものすごく早く穴が落ち始めちゃう
押し始めちゃうんです
それはどんどんスピードアップすると
1箇所を見ると すっとそこに針が落ちてるように見えてしまうんですね
そうすると 私たちにとっては 1つの時間で両方針が穴を打ってるように見える
それ目でどういう風に見えるかと言うと針二本で見えるんです
ちゃんと二本で見える
ですから そんな感じで
この速さで我々にこの別々に仕事しているんだっていうことはわからないんですね
この瞑想で集中させるのはそのためなんですよ
一つのことにとことん集中させる
強引に 集中して集中して
どんどん心はそれに慣れてしまっちゃうんですよ
慣れたら何のことなく
その集中したものに集中しているんですよ
その瞬間で聞くこともできないし
見ることもできないし
体あることもわからないんです
みんなびっくりするんだけど
だからそういうふうな工夫しないと
我々には体験としてこの心の流れが理解できないんです
ですから 瞑想というものは必要な一つの実験になっているんですね
心の速さを理解するために
だから一つに集中してみてください
なかなかできない心はいろんなところやってるんですよ
それでもう随分時間かけて
もう何年でもかけて この集中することはどんどんどんどん成長していって
心が集中することに あるものに集中することに慣れてしまったら
すぐそれに集中できるようになった瞬間で
もう聞こえることもないし
体の感覚もなくなっちゃうんです
体があることをわからなくなっちゃうんです
で その瞬間で なんで体があることがわからなかったんですかとね
体あったのにとかね 頭で思うかもしれませんだけど
あったことはあったんだけど
心の働きで一つの仕事しかしないんだと
一つの時間に一つの仕事しかしない
で 混乱している私たちには
全ての仕事を一緒にやっているんだと
見たり聞いたり考えたり
ああだこうだ全部一緒にやってるんだと思っているだけ
ですから この結晶の場合も
死ぬ死瞬間で 次の瞬間ですごい速く生まれる心が
結晶の心が生まれるんです
ですから 間がないんです
で 人が例えば死んだとする
死んだ瞬間でもう次の心が生まれているんです
この体ではないです どうかわからない
他の場所 で そこに結晶というのは
この流れが切れてないんだからなんです
心という川の流れが切れてない
心はずっと川のように流れている
切れてないんだけど ここで人間として人が死んじゃったんです
でも心は切れてない それでも心は流れている
そこで他のところで他の生命として結晶心が生まれて
そこでまた自分が流れていくんです
その流れに沿って その新しく生まれて
どんどんどんどんじわじわと体が出てきたり
その体が年取ったりして
そこでその体が消えたりするかもしれません
心にとってはそんなことは関係なく
自分が同じ速さで流れていくんです
ですから このチャートで書くならば
例えば人間という形があって
例えば動物という形があったりして
例えば神と形があったり
例えばあるんだとね 考え
そこで心っていうのは一方の流れなんです
そういう風にこの輪廻のことをアビダンマでは
説明できるわけです で
今私たちの心は人間にふさわしいように動いているんですね
この体に それ体の影響なんですよ
もし私が死んだ瞬間で
次に生まれた心が犬の世界だったら
そこから心は同じ速さで流れるんだけど
その時は犬の物質に影響を受けて
それにふさわしい心の波動を打ってしまっちゃうんです
もしその犬が死んだ瞬間で
次に神になってしまったならば
そうすると神という体に必要なように心がそれなりの波動を打ってしまうんですね
それで川も同じで その場所におふさわしい川の流れなんですね
川がすごく深くない場合は
その代わりにすごく広くなってしまう
で 川が細いというところでかなり深くなる
そこで流れていって いろんな石やいろんなものがあるところに行ったら
川が暴れ回っちゃう 水が
そこでそこに崖があったならば
それでも水は止まらない
水はもう崖があろうが何があろうが関係なく流れるんですね
それで崖があったらそこで滝になってしまう
そこであまりも大きい場所でだったら
そこに一時的に湖みたいなものもできる
でも川はそれでも水はそれでも流れていく
そこで湖ができて それからまた出口があって
そこからまた水が流れていく
ですから 水の形はその場所によって変わってしまうんですね
そのように我々の心の働きも
持っている体の状況において変わっちゃうんですね
だから 私にも犬にも同じ心があるんだけど
私には 2 たす 2 は何でしょうかとわかるんだけど
犬にはそれはわからないんです
教えても いろいろ工夫して教えることはできますけど
それでも犬は 2 たす 2 はわかったわけじゃなくて
いろんなことを人間は教えたところで
そういうふうに反応するだけのことなんです
なぜならば 犬の体にはそれは要りません
そんな情報は  2 たす 2 は 4 であろうとも
1 であろうとも 犬はそんなことは関係ないし
犬の生命には全然関係ない
それでも生きていられるんだから
人間は 2 たす 2 はこうだと思っちゃったら生きていられないんです
自動にやっちゃうんです
ですから 人間に必要だから
それは人間もっている
その能力 そういうことだから
心の位置を考える場合は
時空関係でも考えなくちゃいけないんですね
水の状態を説明する場合は
やっぱりその場所のことも必要なんです
なんとか川が滝になるところは
ああいう場所で滝ですよと
こういう場所で湖ですよと
こういう場所でものすごく広くて
なんかゆっくりと流れているんだと
こういう場所はすごい深いんですよと
そういうふうに両方を扱って喋らなくちゃいけない
それで 結晶の場合はどういうことかというと
同じことで 水のように川のように心が流れていく
そこでいろんなところでいろんな体があると
それは場所なんですね
それである体の心が消えた瞬間で
次にまた心 水が流れるんだから
体で消えたんだからといっても
で 次の心は生まれるんですね
そこで場所が違うんです
ですから 場所が違う 時間はもうきちんと決まっている
ですから この結晶心 一つの
まあこっちの 日本訳はこれ
地 どうやって読むんですか
地起  地起 だから地起と書いてるんだから
そこは意味は訳は合ってるんですね
直訳じゃないんで その場合はパーリ語の
まあとにかく心には結晶という働きもあります
その時は場所も考えなくちゃいけないし
時間も考えなくちゃいけない
なぜならば それもまあ時間が決まってるんですからね
地起 結晶は一つ それで受分はまあ
無分心っていうのはバワンガ
チッタ バワンガですね
それはまあ何か認識しない時は心の状態なんですね
で 特別な仕事をしないと
それでも心は流れる 見たり聞いたり感じたり考えたりするのは特別な仕事
そのその生命に必要なように心が動いているんです
犬であろうが猫であろうが人間であろうが
その生命に必要な通りに心が動いてますけど
そういう特別な仕事をしないとき
人間の場合は深い眠りに入っている時とか
夢も見ないで 夢見るということも一つの心の働きなんですね
夢も見ないで深い眠りに入っている時とか
その時も死んでるわけじゃないんだから心は流れているんですね
で その心は無分心と言うんですね
バワンガチッタと言うんです
バワンガっていうのは
バワっていうのは存在
存在をつなげてくれる
という意味でバワンガと言うんですね
で 因縁というのは この心に何か情報が入っちゃうと
体に心に情報が入っちゃうと
このバワンガの心が バワンガというのは寝ている心だから
寝ている心が目が覚めなくちゃいけないんですね
この目が覚める心なんですね
そこで決勝心は一つと無分心は一つと数えて
因縁心は二つなんです
四しかないんだけど 四しかないのにどうやって六になるんでしょうかね
ジャワにはいった？ジャワに入ってない
パキスタンでバワンガ
バワンガ パワーっていうのは心は二つだけ
下に十種  ん？ 下に十種
十種  十種  十種 システムに入ってるんだけど
テキストに入ってないでしょ
なぜ１つ なぜ１つ まあ死心は入るべきなんですけどね
まあそこでなんでテキストに入ってないかっていうことは
だからパティサンディチュティ
バワンガ ワッジナ パンチャ
ワッジナ ターナ ディヴァセナ
パラディサ ダサダー ターナ
ビヒプサカ プーチャ パイカウ
ワカターシーなのにパーリ語のテキストに入ってないんですね
まあ一応まあ死ぬ瞬間も入れて
死ぬ心も入れたら 10種類になりますけど
五識っていうのは眼耳鼻舌身なんですね
で そういう場所で決まってる時間で心が生まれると
ですから 10箇所ですね
心が心が生まれる場所では
まあ何と言いますか 行うというかね
心が現れる まあ機能で時空関係は 10種類があるんだと
いわゆるあるところで条件が揃ったら瞬間ある心が生まれる
その条件揃わなかったら
その特定の心が生まれません
例えばこの体が壊れて
もうカルマも消えちゃって
寿命も消えちゃって エナジーも消えちゃって
行っちゃうと もう認識ほとんどできない状態になってくる
そうすると分身ばっかり生まれたりする
ですから 死ぬ前の人々はほとんど意識がない状態にいるでしょうし
もう考えたりすることもできない
で ほとんど寝ている状態というか
意識ない状態とかあったりして
そこで分身もなかなかできなくなってしまう
分身はただの自然的な流れだから
まあエナジーも消えてしまったら
心はそこでもう生まれなくなっちゃう
それは死心というんです
条件揃わなかったら死心が生まれる
それは瞬間なんです 死心が生まれたら
次の瞬間で決勝心というものは生まれちゃうんです
まあそれで 10種類がありまして
それほど理解してほしいのは
ただこのものは時間と空間
両方の関係で語るんだと
アビダンマではそれだけのことなんですね
この 10番目ではキッチャ
ターナ チッタ バベドと言ったことなんですけど
そこにこの 心を分けてみるんですね
心はどんな働きが どんな心がするんだと
では
ウペッカーサガタサンティーラナニッチェーラアッタマハヴィパカニッチャナヴァルーパールーパヴィパカニッチェーティエクーニヴィーラチッッターニパティサンディバワンガチュティキッチャーニナ
である心がパティサンディ決勝心と分身の働きと
死心ですね その 3つの働きをする
生まれることも 分身も
死ぬことも  3つの働きをする心があるのです
それはどういう心でしょうかと
ここで全部まとめているのです
ウペッカーサガタサンティーラナという心が 2つあるのです
日本訳ではどうなっているんですか？舎利的の随道心
それは心のリストにありました
18の無因心の中に 3箇所に分けて
舎利的の随道心というものは出てきたのです
一つはアクサラヴィパーカ
一つはクサラヴィパーカ
で 心のリストを見るとわかると思います
あの 18のリストの中に七つのグループと八つのグループがあるんです
一番最初だと思いますけどね
テキストの じゃあ提示します
二十六ページ出てくるでしょうね
二十六ページにこの九番でアクサラ・ヴィパーカ・チッタ
七つ出てきて その中に遮蔽の類
類受身と一つあるんですね
受身一つ それから下にアヘトゥカ・クサラ・ヴィパーカというところに
また遮蔽の受身というものが出ているんです
その二つ ん？水道心 サンティラ・チッタ
水道心 その二つ あの まあ一応あの
わかりやすくするためにここで説明しますけど
本当はそれを覚えておかないと
まあなかなかアビダンマ進めなくなりますけど
で この一番目九番目見てください
アクサラ・ヴィパ あの二十六ページの九番目
アクサラ・ヴィパーカ・チッタと書いて
アクサラ・ヴィパーカというのは不善いじく心なんですね
で 不善いじく心のセット
七つのセットの中に あの
この水道心一つあるんですね
サンティールナ・チッタ
パーリ語で読めたらすごくわかりやすいんだけど
この あの不善いじく心の水道心で
結晶心として働くんですね
今言ったのはそういうことなんですね
その心が結晶する働きをしてくれるんです
結晶っていうのは生まれ変わることなんですよ
ですから その場合は不善いじく心なんですね
この不善いじく心が結晶の働きをする
そこで不善いじく心ですから
やっぱり悪いところに生まれちゃうんですね
ですから この悪いところに生まれる動物とかね
そういう悪いと もう人間よりレベルの高くないところに
殺すだけ生まれるところに生まれる生命は
その心で生まれるんですね
仏教から言えば まあ地獄やら餓鬼道やら畜生やら餓鬼道やらね
そういうクラスありますね
あの なんでしたっけ？地獄
餓鬼道 畜生と阿修羅でしたっけ
四つの生命の次元があるんだと
そこら辺に生まれる その人々のはその人々の生まれる心がこの不善意熟心の衰道心です
その心で生まれたんです
で 次にあの 善意熟心八ありますね
十番目に二十六ページの十番目に無因善意熟心というところに八がありまして
その中にもまた一つ 射具の衰道心があるんですね
その射具のその射具の衰道心にも結生の働きはできるんです
で その場合はどこに生まれ変わるかというと
だいたい人間の世界ですけど
人間なんですが 人間としてはもう行動することはできない
という人々もいるんでしょう
一応人間で生まれたんだけど
普通の人間としてはもう何もできない
まあ大変重たいな 障害をいろいろ持ってきて
持って生まれて 大変なんて言いますか
不孝と言えば不孝かもしれませんだけど
大変苦しい生き方をしなくちゃいけない
死ぬまでご飯食べさせなくちゃいけないとかね
もう誰か体を洗ってあげなくちゃいけないとかね
全然言葉も喋れないとかね
まるっきり頭が働かなくて
もう何も勉強も何もできないとかね
そういうふうにこのいろんな障害を持って生まれちゃうんですね
この障害を持って生まれたんだけど
まあ形は人間ですけど
人間として自由に行動して動くことはできない
その人々の場合は 生まれた結生心はこの意熟
善意熟心なんですが この衰道心なんです
で とにかく人間に生まれることはいいカルマの結果なんです
とにかく 形どうであろうか
そのカルマ自体のエネルギーは随分弱くなったら
この無因心の衰道心で生まれちゃうんです
そうすると人間としてはそういうエネルギーは足らないんです
でも人間に生まれたんだから
まあそれなりに楽をするかもしれませんね
それなりの楽をいはしますよ
でも人間としては大変ダメなんです
だから動物と同じかというと
それでもないし で そういう風な
この 次にこの心の世界で
この 二十九ページにこのマハークスレチッタというものがあります
日本訳は三十ページからなんですけど
欲界上心二十四があります
そこに大善心八があります
この大善心というのは
人間が善行為をする時生まれる心なんですね
その心の結果として生まれる心はマハーヴィパークチッタで
三十一ページの十六番目
大意熟心とは言っているんです
大意熟心八あります この大意熟心八も結生の働きはするんです
いわゆる生まれ変わる時は
その大意熟心八の一つで生まれ変わっちゃう
その場合はいいカルマの結果なんですね
その心はどこに生まれるかというと
人間の世界と天界 ですから
普通のノーマルな人間に生まれる人の結生心はこの八つの中の一つなんです
どっちかちょっと言いにくいんだけど
普通なノーマルな人間も体も健康的で
頭も良くて ごく普通に生まれている人々は
この心はこの八つの一つなんです
で それで天界の神になる人々の心もその八つの一つなんです
その八つの順番では 一番目はすごく力強い
二番目はわずかに力 わずかに弱いですけど
その八つのリストの中で智慧入っている心は四つあります
智慧が入っている心四つはものすごく力強い
智慧が入ってない心の四つはそれほど力がない
わずかに力が弱い